[Music]
thank you to brilliant for supporting
PBS Digital Studios when you hear the
phrase the American Dream what picture
comes to mind for a long time the
classic version included a white picket
fence wait five children and of course
house the importance of home ownership
is still embedded in American culture
seven and ten adults say they want to
own their own home someday and yet
actual home ownership has dropped to its
lowest level since 1967 the biggest
culprit those pesky Millennials with an
18% decrease since 2004
if owning a house is still important
that our young people just being foolish
or are they reacting rationally to a
changing economy
[Music]
in theory owning a home still makes a
lot of sense because it kills to
financial birds with one stone it's a
place to live and a long-term investment
every time you make a mortgage payment
or the value of your home increases
you're saving money for your future self
it's like a piggy bank you can sleep in
but the world is changing in ways that
make this scenario harder to pull off
younger people have more debt than
previous generations mainly thanks to
student loans the average amount that a
graduate owes has tripled in the last 25
years which means that many young people
already have a house sized debt cloud
hanging over them without even having an
asset to sell as if that wasn't bad
enough Millennials have a larger burden
for retirement in ye olden days the
average American could expect three
sources of income to support them in
their autumn years a pension social
security and personal retirement savings
but thanks to shifting labor trends and
shrinking unions pensions are quickly
becoming a thing of the past and it's
giving this three-legged stool a major
wobble and since we can't expect Social
Security payments to substantially
increase anytime soon younger people
will be expected to make up the
difference with larger retirement
savings which means less cash on hand to
put towards a house the shifting labor
market has also led to more pressure to
be geographically flexible instead of
being tied down to one location and the
importance of travel for young people is
at an all-time high in the u.s.
Millennials rank Travel as more
important than homeownership and report
that they're more likely to set aside
money for that rather than buying a home
considering these factors it's no wonder
Millennials are viewing homeownership as
more of an option than a necessity so is
it an option that's right for you here
are some questions to ask yourself one
can I get good mortgage terms unless
you've got hundreds of thousands of
dollars sitting around in cash you're
gonna have to borrow the money and pay
for the privilege how much you'll pay an
interest is determined by a number of
factors but generally speaking in order
to qualify for terms that make home
buying a good investment you'll need a
consistent provable source of income
a credit score of 760 or higher and a
down payment at or close to 20% of the
home price if you can't meet these
requirements it might not be the right
time to buy a home - will I have
emergency money left over the money who
have wrapped up in your house isn't
liquid meaning you wouldn't be able to
get to it easily if you need it so if
your a/c breaks down or your car needs
repairs and you don't have any emergency
funds set aside the only thing you'll
have to cling to is debt which is more
of a lead weight than a life vest so be
sure you have at least three times your
monthly expenses left over after your
down payment three can I stick around
for at least five years find a house
that you have to sell again quickly
probably won't end well you have to
consider upfront costs like Realtors and
inspections plus at the beginning of
your mortgage most of your monthly
payment is going towards interest
meaning your debt isn't actually
shrinking that much for many buyers it
can begin decade or more before that
ratio is even 50/50 so how do these
factors shake out in a real world
example let's run the numbers
this is Ramon Ramon has a good steady
job he's been saving money and he's
thinking about buying a house for around
two hundred thousand he only has enough
for a 15% down payment and no emergency
fund also there's a chance Ramon might
decide to relocate to New York with his
girlfriend when she graduates from law
school into three years by that time
Ramon will only pay off around nine
thousand dollars of the loan principal
so if their home value increases by
average of five percent he'll be able to
sell it for a bit more than you bought
it for but that's not counting to real
turkeys property taxes are not cute if
everything goes perfectly smoothly from
one we'll just break even but if just
one thing goes wrong like losing a job
for six months or he has to replace his
home's roof or a/c it's a different
picture
Ramon might want to hold off on buying a
house for now if you're like Ramon don't
freak out you could never buy a home but
still be okay financially there are even
some perks like not being responsible
for maintenance costs and being able to
easily pack up and move if you get a
better job opportunity but investing is
like exercise some workouts deliver
better results than others but anything
is better than doing nothing so if
you're not gonna buy a house it's extra
important that you are making
investments in other areas like a 401k
or a company that you own there's no
sugarcoating it when it comes to home
buying Milani house got a tough deal but
you can overcome that disadvantage by
understanding your situation and
starting to plan for it now and that's
our two cents one of our favorite
segments of two cents is run the numbers
we take a financial concept and put it
in the real world with real financial
calculations it's pretty cool to see how
small things can become big things over
time from compound interest rates to
hidden fees that stack up maybe you want
to see how much interest you'll pay over
the lifetime of a mortgage or how much
you'd end up with if you quit your gym
membership and invested that money
instead with a little hands-on practice
you
can master the art of personal finance -
one fun easy way to hone your financial
math skills is that brilliant dot-org
they offer practical hands-on lessons in
math and science
each lesson puts you in the driver's
seat and allows you to run the numbers
for your own life for more information
about brilliant head - brilliant
org slash - cents
[Music]